mmm cold but not cold enough it's colder
but still not cold enough nope nope nope
not cold enough and we want real cold
weather we got to go to Alaska
[Applause]
it's a lovely winter day here in
Northern Virginia and the Nichols family
thinks it's not cold enough we are going
to Alaska we're gonna be camping ice
fishing it's gonna be pretty awesome all
right you guys ready to go to Alaska
[Music]
[Music]
well it's 2:30 in the morning
Anchorage time that makes it 6:30 in the
morning Virginia time but we made it we
are going to get some sleep and I will
see you in the morning maybe four hours
but we're up and Melody's up too and
it's an exciting new day and we're gonna
have fun wall - hi laughs well I
anticipate us doing some serious winter
camping so I had a bunch of reindeer
hides shift to Melanie's house that I'm
excited to go test about we walked next
door to Grandma grandpa's house and the
boys are getting their groove on to some
Bon Jovi
[Music]
is that cozy three degrees Farenheit
outside let's go get some winter clothes
shall we alright if you need serious
cold-weather gear especially in big boy
sizes this is a great place to go got
myself a set of negative forty boots got
these insulated pants here they go under
your bibs
alright guys we bought out half the
store we are so geared up well we did
some shopping now we need to get some
lunch so we're here at the fire tap and
we're gonna get some food for Becca and
for the boys you guys hungry
oh look at the size of that pretzel
mustard and cheese alright need your
true Alaskan you're gonna run barefoot
through the snow just to avoid having to
put shoes on cold feet cold feet nice
thing about the winners is you get long
nights and lots of time to cuddle up as
a family and spend some time together be
next nulling well it is a brisk negative
six and we're heading off to church got
the kids loaded up and this car may
never warm up it's so cold
you guys ready to go to cold church
we're driving back home from church and
there's a big old moose on the side of
the road kill you over to Grandma's
house we're having an army men battle
here okay I got this divider so many
brave young men I love it I've got my
full parka and the boys are dawning ski
goggles to go visit my grandpa
well it's 4:30 so the Sun setting time
to go get some dinner well we've had a
great time visiting a family but we are
so tired the jetlag is caught up to me
so it's like 9 o'clock I'm going to bed
I'll see you in the morning all right we
got ninja Tommy and Nathan we're dressed
up for walking out to the warm car
[Music]
for sausage but we're gonna go in the
garage here and we're gonna make a
rocket stove and I've got to go and
sharpen up the axe here a little bit
before you go camping tomorrow I got a
big birch log here I'm gonna turn this
thing into a rocket stove so we can cook
some trout on it while we go Asian oh
there we go we can see light
all right get dressed get you stuck and
we're here at little city lake inside of
Anchorage and we're gonna try to catch
some little stocked rainbow trout all
right let's try this spot yeah fresh one
really pull it up yeah there we go
little stock trout cook them little tiny
rainbow travel stocks rainbow trout you
want to eat some trout come over here
yeah you want some all right well guys
well let's pack it up and we're gonna
head back was that fun
good morning it's a beautiful Wednesday
the Sun is not up and me and Nathan are
getting up heading in the car and we're
gonna be driving out into the mountains
for some camping let's go get some food
I'll I'll take a burger
oh that's a good fritter still warm well
it's a balmy six degrees Fahrenheit here
and I think it's a perfect day to go
camping
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right I think this is where we're
gonna make our campsite right here just
sleep under the caribou hide all right
you slept in a lot what happened I I had
to do I'll just throw some trash in my
mouth
meanwhile we're going to Whittier look
once
Grandma and Grandpa can see over by
Wireless the Sun is showing on the
mountain you might go see him well here
we are we're waiting to go through the
Whittier tunnel we have to go onto
schedule to get through the tunnel
because it's just one lane and then
trains go through sometimes two I mean
while we're driving to see the train
tracks in there we're gonna go see if we
can find Luke amazing besides he's a
little boy walking down the road I'm
like that looks just like Tommy it is
Tommy they stopped by to say hi and it's
the best surprise ever two hours late oh
oh yeah go poo buddy and you don't poo
in your winter camping you just hold it
in till spring well you know we had the
reindeer hides we were camping with well
I wanted something a little bit more
because I knew it was gonna be super
cold so I actually ordered a buffalo
hide unfortunately it came a day too
late but here it is so maybe we're gonna
have to do another another video see the
problem with the reindeer hides is it
takes two to cover me so I needed just a
bigger animal hide so Buffalo it is I am
exhausted and I am going to lay on a
couch for a very long time but my sweet
wife here is going to the Imaginarium or
some sort of kids museum with grandma
and the boys so she's gonna do the
filming well it's going in
[Music]
my hair yay Jacob's back alright let's
go over to Grandma's house for dinner
[Music]
man you guys got dance moves over new
buy a new my new my age I'm editing
video I'm gonna watch a movie and go to
go to bed very early so I'll see you
guys tomorrow
all right guys let's go sledding go and
get dressed get dressed we're going
sledding yeah we're at the park well
we're here at Ocean View bluff park
right around sunset which means it's
like 3b is the first time with the boys
that they've ever gone sledding on any
real Hill hey dig up do I go sledding
[Laughter]
fun except for all this spray in the
face at 8 degrees it's cold put your
feet inside the slide there you go
[Music]
hey guys
mobs corpses joined us here mama
your life this place brings back a lot
of memories this was our local park
growing up as a kid it tell me what do
you think it's lighting is it backwards
every die haha let's try out big birth
over
[Applause]
[Applause]
this might be the last run of the day
let's do it this trip is going by fast
oh yeah it's the slow jam of sunsets a
smile are you having fun Tavia are you
having a ball
yes I do not want to leave us here all
night all day all night all day and
sledge ready let's run big account
[Laughter]
well good morning me and the boys are
frantically getting ready because we are
traveling into the interior of Alaska to
do some hardcore ice fishing supposed to
be like negative 17 or something out at
Lake Louise we better bring our winter
gear plan to leave at 10 pull it out at
noon that's how we roll
are your reindeers buckled up good
[Music]
[Music]
all right I think we're here and we're
with Jake from how to Alaska and we're
swinging by here and there just showed
us a little hospitality the good time
you guys never seen his channel
definitely check it out
look at this this is his Alaskan as you
get a young lady on her pink snow
machine doing laughs around a dead
caribou that is Alaska all right neat do
you want to try this this makes it go
and this stops it okay
Nathan did you like that did you have
loads of fun got caribou ribs here from
the ones ldr that's locally sourced I
heard that's a good thing you want to
eat some here buddy Nathan Tommy you
guys time to go
are you having fun with friends yeah you
want to stay here or do you want to go
fishing
yeah I know you do all right guys ready
go up Lake Louise let's do it
well guys we're here at the point lodge
at lake louise we are going to be doing
some serious ice fishing tomorrow but
tonight we are going to take it easy
eat some food and just relax a little
bit for negative twenty degrees
Fahrenheit we have got piles and piles
of clothes here Nathan are you ready to
get bundled up
what you guys think you like that you go
inside the shack it's warm all right
here we go
oh it's nice and warm inside
[Music]
yes we are darn close to negative 40
degrees Fahrenheit which for all you
people who like metric system out there
is negative 40 Celsius now Patrick over
here has no gloves just pure manliness
yeah he's he's scooping the ice out with
his bare fingers because he is the
Alaskan man anything you haven't fun
Tommy you have a good time see look
right there it's coming right up that
fish came right up off the bottom and
he's he is checking you out right there
[Music]
oh that is a beautiful beautiful lake
trout bud yeah oh yeah yeah yeah bright
that's orange like a salmon yep
slow dig doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo so my brother here
he has in his hand let me let me get
that in the light oh look at look at
that
this is seal-oil a traditional Native
Alaskan delicacy it's hard to get a hold
of it Brett Kirk from no attack hooked
us up here and it's got some seal oil
with some dried bearded seal meat
floating in there and a chunk of
whitefish first I've got smell is it oh
that is a that is a pungent smell
do you know what that smells like to me
like cured salmon eggs to me it smells
like like a cooking oil with a little
bit yeah but you have a chunk of dried
seal meat they're out there dried be at
the rib me rib meat of a bearded seal
and it's dried not smoked right no it's
it's not cooked it's dry just ride
that's intense you really kind of
rehydrated in my mouth a little bit it
was like I'd been a chunk out of a seal
[Laughter]
chugalug
we just come sprinting over in the logs
all the way bend over minded gonna need
a bigger hole oh snap yeah hole was all
froze up well we've had an absolute ball
here and we'd love to fish longer but
we've got to drive all the way back to
Anchorage tonight
[Music]
did you guys have fun ice fishing well
it's a beautiful Sunday morning in our
last day here at Alaska we are going to
church and then we're gonna visit some
family and then we have to pack up and
go home thank you what was your favorite
part about the trip I seen family
driving to Whittier and painting with
your mom hey tell me what was your
favorite part of the trip
what was your favorite part of this trip
well you guys left
say goodbye to cousin
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh it's so good to be home I hope you
guys enjoyed this video and coming along
with us on our vacation and adventures
if you want to see more great travel
adventures from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel we've got a whole playlist full
of those adventures don't forget to
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like that
and don't forget to click Subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that belt
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]